darling you look stunning  you look amazing butterfly it's not new  okay you know what it's part of your  power Mariah how do you feel today being  honored for your power you are a  powerful iconic one well thank you  darling  I don't often think of myself that way  but I was very honored that they  included me with this incredible bunch  of powerful women we're getting the  memoir soon what's that gonna be darling  you're not ready no I really mean it  yeah revealing um honest and just a  really cathartic experience that I'm  working on it yeah my last question for  you there are crazy rumors that you are  on the masked singer with Nick is this  true  bye girl bye  you